- Malgré la chaude journée,
Maurice Blais, un résident
du CHSLD de Saint-Michel-
de-Bellechasse, apprécie
son tour de vélo-taxi
dans le village.
MAURICE BLAIS, Résident, CHSLD
Vigi Notre-Dame de Lourdes
- Je recommencerais.
- Pourquoi?
Qu'est-ce que ça vous apporte?
- C'est une certaine liberté.
- C'est justement ce sentiment
ertéertéertéerté que souhaitaitr
la propriétaire de l'entreprise
de location de vélo électrique
VéloPop.
DANY GAGNON,
fondatrilolololoPop!
- Je voyais ces gens là
qui habitaient dans le CHSLD
et qui faisaient des petites
sorties en fauteuil roulant, qui
oioioiois venaient sur le gazon
juste à côté de moi et je me
disais : "C'est comme injuste,
il faut qu'il y ait quelque
chose pour eux."- - - - Après d,
Dany Gagnon trouve finalement
un vélo pouvant accueillir
jusqu'à 2 passagers. Seul hic,
il est fabriqué au Danemark,
et pour l'importer,
il faut débourser 17 000 $.
Une somme que ne pouvait
se permettre l'entreprise.
- En parlant avec la députée
de Bellechasse, elle m'a comme
jumelée avec la Fondation Rayon
D'espoir. Puis, donc, je leur ai
écrit, puis ils m'ont rapidement
répondu.
HÉLÈNE FORGUE, administratrice,
Fondation Le Rayon d'Espoir
- Pour nous, ça entrait
directement dans notre mission
d'offrir une activité qui
améliore la qualité de vie
des aînés.
- La fondation a donc acheté
le vélo. VéloPop! assure
de son côté les formations
des intervenants en loisirs
qui peuvent à lurururur utiliser
le vélo pour offrir une balade
aux résidents en CHSLD.
- J'ai vu des maisons,
des belles maisons.
J'ai trouvé qu'il y avait des
bosses dans les rues, des trous.
(rires)
- Mais ça reste confortable?
- Oh, que oui! Je passerais
la journée ici.
- Certains résidents sont dans
le CHSLD de leur village natal,
donc ilst t t t leur quartier,
ils revoient leur maison,
leurs voisins. Les intervenants
nous disent aussi que ça réduit
l'anxiété.
- Cinq CHSLD de la région
de Bellechasse en bénéficient
en semaine, alors que les fins
de semaine, le bolide sur trois
roues est disponible en location
pour tous.
- Ça peut être des grands
enfants de 50 ans qui promènent,
comme ça peut être des enfants
de 40 ans qui promènent
leurs enfants de 5 ans, 6 ans.
- n n n n prochain,
l'entrepreneure espère offrir
des tours guidés de la région
à vélo.
Ici Louis-Philippe Arsena
Radio-Canada, Saint-Michel-
de-Bellechass